I've built multiple 10 million dollar
plus companies I don't know how to do
anything I don't have any web
development skills I don't have video
editing skills I don't have design
skills I don't have any skills I can
write all right I can write books and I
can speak but that's it I'm an
organizing Force I'm the guy who just
organizes it 10 grand is not a lot to
certain people if you've already got a
half a million pound business a half a
million dollar business 10 grand okay
yeah we can do that anyone who can run a
pub can run your business a pub has
drunk people and people like hooking up
and having relationships a pub is like
got razor thin margins you just do not
need to be running your business that's
not what you're good at as a key person
of influence you should be out there
doing the thing that only you can do
thank you